this is the second part of the breathing
film so I'm going to use a gel and a can
but not that you should be looking at it
for technical points because I'm just
going to show you this top half
and it's about the breath
and I've said on an earlier film with
the Joe that
[Music]
um
I sort of disagree with um size of
Sensei making us count
because when he
um you know in his younger days if he'd
done it very dynamically and powerfully
you don't hear him counting he's just
going flat out and also the teachers
that I trained with in my younger period
when I was also hopefully Dynamic and
fast you don't have time to count it
would just be gibberish whatever
his necessary
it's just been a pointless exercise
I think because he sort of wanted to
take those senses Technical and make
sure that the world knew about the
simplest of osensei's work
and and how the world seems to want to
complicate it
but this gave him what he called the one
two three method
and everything has a account with the
partner Ken you would cut step to the
side and you would count he would say
two seconds but we would actually find
it would be more like five seconds uh
what he considered to us too
the point I'm trying to make here is
he had a counting method accounting
system he created to my knowledge oh
since he didn't
so when he says it's a 31 count Carter
he insisted that we all counted but that
was only when we were going through the
form like Edge and then we would do it
and what I've found
in the students around the world who I'm
teaching
if their teachers before me or even in
my class they get misinterpreted and
what you're saying if you're going to
count
if you're going to count
and you start by going Edge
knee
the count may start slightly earlier
than the
than the action
but you have you haven't got any power
the breath is going to stimulate the
body and the body is going to call forth
this power
we call it Coke you in Aikido itchy cool
in the Tai Chi Parana in yoga
you know and so it goes on and I'm
showing all the different languages
around the world it'll have a name but
it means using the breath to its best
and if you're going to use the breath to
its best you can't do it if you're going
to be counting
so there's so I encountered you again
like in the early films so
Edge
in breath
I
action
count in breath action not
in breath or we don't even in a lot of
cases people are not even thinking about
their breath this is even worse
so it's not
Edge because you don't you're finding
breath that's obviously come in without
thought
but what use is it
because you haven't summed up summoned
up
a great power you've just so expelled
what you've got in your lungs
so if you breathe in through the nose
Edge
[Music]
and then call forth your breath and push
it out your whole both lungs
will push this power out I had a teacher
once who when young had a lung removed
but he had a lung removed he'd become a
top teacher in the UK Mr Hayden Foster
she only had one lung
but you'd never know it watching him
dynamically teach year after year and of
course he said that Aikido made him
stronger
therefore made his lungs the one lung
stronger and made it work his most
efficient
so I'll go over again
breathe in through the nose
couch itch
expel
now
I'm going to say the same as they can
but like a jug pouring water
into a small receptacle
as you pour it if the mouth is small of
the receptacle
then
your poor sensibly
you were pouring into a bucket you could
just pour it
but the breath needs to be like pouring
into something small
so that you You observe what you're
doing
now
the breath once practiced a new and at
night practicing for years don't think
you're going to get this in a week or
months even it's going to need to be
practice year after year in different
formats perhaps through different arts
different exercises
you will perform this until you realize
that
you'll learn to be able to control the
balance and quality where you're not
sort of holding yourself tense with
holding the breath and then let it all
out you will take this in
and you'll release it efficiently
then we get to the next stage
where in the original
iwama training we would have to do Kia
since he would shout at you if you
didn't and they said you could hear a
census key eyes across the other side of
the village
I don't know if that's a fairy tale but
it's a very big Village when I've been
there so I think that must have been a
very still night all the wind carrying
is uh his key eye
but anyhow you can make a key eye very
loud if you're in full breath and you're
in full committed power
we call this koku
okay so as with pour in The Jug through
a small receptacle I'm going to now say
that The Jug has
kale the Jack holds the key eye
so the power comes from the key eye
but you don't have Kia without control
of breath and you don't have breath
without control of body
and mind the mind has to tell the body
how how it comes in how it goes out
the timing of not counting while
doing the action
is the same as
thought process
action not thought while doing the
action
how you can see the overlap it's the yin
and yang Factor
breathing in
pushing it deep down into your body this
is muscular
but not so you feel
tense
so breathing in
Edge
[Music]
I'm not going to make a loud key all
right because I'm in a village myself
and I'm working in the garden
but this key I should
ring out
I don't want to frighten the neighbors
of the people
nearby so please forgive me for that I
would just make the sound but it's a
controlled key eye
from the breath
Edge
hey
[Music]
and of course the key eye and breath is
longer on the out and on the end as I've
talked about in the first film